Chris Mannix joins us on loan from Yahoo
Sports their senior NBA writer did you
write off the Celtics last night when
they're down 22 Mannix no only because
you know I've seen this story too many
times this season I don't know how many
I don't know who leads the league in you
know wins after being down by like 15
plus points but Boston's got to be high
on that list and even though they're
completely undermanned I mean hey I kind
of made this joke in the column down
there there one injury away from having
like invincible style tryouts to fill
out one of these roster spots out there
even undermanned they they're they just
are so disciplined and can get offense
from anywhere so they've dug in in that
second quarter and change the dynamic of
the game and and we can get into this
but I thought you know a couple of
critical coaching errors by Philadelphia
really changed the course that game well
you had TJ who was playing better at the
point guard position than Ben Simmons
was but he had to put Ben Simmons back
in well I mean well I think I I think
Rao wise doesn't it feel like you know
that's one of those if you don't put him
back in and then all of a sudden he
pouts and then you know does their carry
over to Game three I don't know I don't
know how it works
I don't know Dan would look this is look
I think Brett Brown is an unbelievable
coach and what he's done with that team
is really remarkable keeping them you
know kind of in a positive way even
through all the losing but let me ask
you this with a Popovich or a Doc Rivers
or a more experienced playoff coach have
recognized that TJ McConnell was giving
Boston problems I mean I talked to a
couple of Celtics staffers last night
after the game and you know one thing
they said to me was TJ McConnell didn't
just kill them in this game TJ McConnell
always kills them like for some reason
they have a problem with what TJ
McConnell does what a more experienced
coach have said you know what screw it
you know I'll deal with the pouting
we're here to win a game and left the
guy there was a plus 17 when he came out
in that game I'm not sure the reason why
Ben Simmons struggled you know if you
say it's mental I don't know what that
means if were they physical with him
okay I can understand that
but I think if you're the head coach of
the 76ers you're assuming Ben Simmons is
going to rally and have some kind of
performance there I'm gonna play the
odds and I still have to play Ben
Simmons but I did understand the TJ
McConnell was playing better and not
trying to force thing has been Simmons
yeah I just I did disagree I mean Ben
Simmons was stinking up the joint last
night even though we put up good numbers
in Game one his shot chart he won't
shoot from outside of you know really
three feet in the paint and McConnell
was pesky defensively he was creating
for teammates I think you've got a ride
with the hot hand there that was a
problem I think an equal problem oh damn
that that changed the course of this
game the last like six minutes of the
second quarter when Boston turned a 22
point lead into five no timeouts yeah
that's a great I mean you're you're
saving time outs in the second quarter
of a game those were were kind of
tactical errors that I think in the
years to come
a guy like Brett Brown won't make we had
Frank Isola on from the New York Daily
News in his column today mr. good news
when it comes to know he likes there are
certain members of the media who really
love them some David phys Dale so fish
Dale comes to town and in his column he
says well Fez Dale has a great
relationship with LeBron James from
their days with the Miami Heat
we've not talked about the Knicks as a
destination for any free agents in a
long time could you see this being
different with LeBron and David fizz
Dale in New York it's interesting
because I haven't really thought about
it because in the phys Dale is the one
bridge that that maybe could connect
LeBron and make him believe that New
York was a winning situation because the
last 15 20 years when have they ever
been kind of a functional situation it's
been you know one coach after the other
one regime change after the other that
the relationship I can tell you between
LeBron and fizz Dale is very strong so
does it move the needle towards that
yeah but I still think New York has to
be a long shot to land them because they
are years away from being able to win
unless there's I we talk all the time
then about LeBron and somebody else
right
John and Paul George LeBron and DeMarcus
Cousins unless it's a package deal I
can't see LeBron going to New York
talking to Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports
senior NBA writer we had Reggie Miller
on and we were redrafting this is the
Kyrie Irving klay Thompson Kawhi Leonard
Jimmy Butler draft right now if you're
if you're read rap knowing what you know
about these players who would you take
first overall in that and that draft all
those guys I'm missing somebody that
that is gonna is if there's somebody
else besides those three you name that
is in that mix well Jimmy Butler is also
in there so well yeah I still think I
read I mean I the only reason not to
take Kyrie is the knee issue and if
we're taking that kind of off the table
if we're assuming that in his mid 20s
he's gonna be able to get past this this
knee injury he's still the one guy I
think offensively is capable of winning
games for you by himself and carrying
them he's not the freeway player clay
and Jimmy are but I think his offense
transcends them I was also thinking
about this that if the Celtics play the
Cavaliers do you realize that all of the
players involved in that big trade
nobody's going to be playing in this
increase coming up it's incredible like
crazy how they how did they get to this
point either team get to this point I
mean by alright Cleveland should have
lost that first round series against
Indiana Indiana I'll claim them Toronto
is a different team and they're getting
smoked Boston has no business being
where they are with the guys I mean any
other way could you know walk down the
street outside your studio dad I don't
know who would recognize him and he's
playing minutes for this team you know
they're just holding guys out there that
aren't used to playing these holes and
they're getting contributions from them
it really is I don't know and I put this
on Twitter last night I don't look more
remarkable the Cavs do nothing serious
lead or Boston to nothing seriously
because both of them I think are pretty
improbable any concerns with the Rockets
going into Game three with his own I
liked what the Jazz did defensively is
it duplicate Bowl at with the
adjustments that a Mike D'Antoni coach
team can make I don't know what what the
Jazz did was in some
it looked like they took a page out of
Boston's playbook right like Boston has
decided in this series that if embiid
and Ben Simmons can beat them 101
they'll take that they're not going to
allow the three-point shooters as best
they can any way to beat from the
outside that was the attitude that you
said that Utah took with Houston in Game
two they said look Clint capela can go
for 20-plus will live with Clint capela
beating us you're not going to have
Gordon and Hart and these guys knocking
down three point shots regularly now
Houston's going to adjust and there's
more talent there especially with the
great Ricky Rubio lineup but I think
defensively is where I where this game
is gonna be won or lost for the Jazz
lady is Rubio gonna play in Game three
unclear but I did I feel like you you
overlooked the great Dante Exum my next
favorite player yeah you're right yeah
you were all in a Mathieu the off the
icon Dante Exum II honestly just taking
over these games defensively coming back
from what was believed to be a
season-ending shoulder injury icon I did
say to Donovan Mitchell when he joined
us earlier in the week then I'm a better
shooter than Ricky Rubio just so you
know I don't say stuff like you know to
you or privately I just say it right to
if Ricky Rubio came on I'd say Rick
loved your game the man buns okay I'm a
better shooter than you yeah you know
he's a better passer better ball handler
but I'm a better shooter than Ricky
Rubio but I told Mitchell I said you
know I can help Ricky Rubio I can give
him a tutorial in the offseason I'll
come out to Utah I'll go to wherever I
need to go to help Ricky Rubio so I'm
just letting you know yet why do you
have to disparage Ricky Rubio when he's
hurt like why do you have to but his
feelings are always hurt whether he's
healthy or not his feelings are always
hurt we came away going whoa whoa we got
a new favorite man he was awesome he was
a lot of fun good kid
so there are and look and think about
the respected young players get in this
league like Ben Simmons gets a lot of
respect
- I taught you a lot of players about
their favorite young guys the Oklahoma
City guys I've talked to about this I
talked to Chris Paul about this recently
the guys they love to watch a young guy
dad what the most respect for if you get
a pole across the NBA
I bet Donovan Mitchell wins it in a
landslide there's something about this
kid's game that everybody just loves and
I think he's gonna be a superstar as we
keep the text messages emails coming we
appreciate that the icon yes yes of
course that's Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports
NBA writer and he's the proud president
of the Ricky Rubio fan club might be the
only member what that's mean-spirited
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]